[Music]
big indication Captain's Log
we've been submerged for weeks and are
only now seeing the first signs of the
Sargasso Sea there are far more baby sea
turtles here than I expected and the
Sargassum seaweed is a singular almost
yellowish shade of green and especially
thick I said my camera's out to explore
and dictation the Sargasso Sea is
located here zoom out it's the only sea
in the world that is not defined by any
land boundaries but instead by ocean
currents and it's known for its endemic
and anomalous seaweed
this a Sargassum there is nearly 10
million tons of it floating on the sea
surface as this seaweed has no root
system you might recognize it as it
often washes up on Caribbean beaches
many scientists call the Sargasso Sea a
nursery in the open ocean because it
provides food and shelter for many of
the Atlantic oceans infants most common
our baby loggerhead sea turtles who
after hatching swim here to mature young
eels shrimp crabs mahi-mahi and Marlins
also maturate here in the Sargasso Sea
blue what's that that thing floating
there it's plastic got to be a plastic
the Sargasso Sea is also home to the
North Atlantic Garbage Patch trash from
around the planet gathers here thanks to
multiple competing currents it's a
human-made maritime disaster that's why
we only use biodegradable plastic on
this submarine and no straws
[Music]
look captain I think one of the infants
is taking a liking to the ship so he has
Brian so he has
[Music]
check the sonar do we have a lock on it
50 feet captain I'm reading her to be at
least 28 feet long 28 feet Great Scott
[Music]
legends have told of a giant sea serpent
there
[Music]
the inspiration for legends of sea
serpents and monsters the giant oarfish
is a peculiar animal it's the world's
longest bony fish and has been known to
reach lengths of up to 56 feet of those
we've been able to study they typically
weigh in at around 600 pounds or fish
can be found in every ocean on the
planet except the Arctic they're what's
known as an ocean honest species what it
means the fish's migratory and travels
across the world's oceans exactly or
fish migrate to find their food mainly
plankton and krill while the fish may be
large it has no real teeth but rather
gill rakers that filter out its food
from the ocean water the giant oarfish
is typically a deep ocean fish its
natural habitat is around 3,000 feet
deep but it has often been seen
shallower sometimes as shallow as 60
feet
you know it's strange rather than
swimming schools the giant oarfish
chooses a solitary life circumnavigating
the planet endless search for food I
like to think it's on a grand adventure
kind of like all of us is Reacher
captain
can't you see I'm having a moment
[Music]
captain's log 53 days and still no sign
of finally I see we'd made it Duggar
here
[Music]
welcome to California's majestic kelp
forest the redwoods of the ocean
[Music]
kelp is one of the fastest growing
plants on earth some species can grow up
to 24 inches per day giant kelp like the
ones around us can reach upwards of 200
feet that's taller than the Leaning
Tower of Pisa
exactly kelp force thrive in cool
coastal waters and are home to hundreds
of different types of animals like seals
sea lions lobster fish sea otters
merchants even octopi more than just
cold water
kelp likes turbulent thanks these
turbulent waters are constantly stirring
up nutrients the kelp needs to survive
unfortunately these forests off Catalina
are suffering from the effects of
climate change and warming ocean
temperatures beautiful isn't it
I have an idea gather round everyone
let's take it comfy get it they don't
get it
[Music]
what's our depth it does raise 4000
people of sea level captain nice and
easy now Lander softly we have video
bring it up
holy [ __ ]
we're at the Westmount a volcano a
hundred and forty miles southwest of
Samoa here this volcano although
thousands of feet beneath the water's
surface 3937 feet to be exact this
volcano although 3937 feet beneath the
water surface is still actively spewing
out liquid hot magma in fact many of the
world's most active volcanoes are
underwater
let's get will on the line dr. Sager hi
how's time to myseif still messy it's
still big still the biggest volcano in
the world do we know about captain Durst
oh well tell me more does the Savior
well tamo Massey is really really big it
stands two and a half miles tall over
the ocean bottom but it's really really
wide it's a hundred and twenty thousand
square miles in area that's a go can you
copy
we lost him what will is saying is that
Tonga Massif is extremely stout
despite being 2.5 miles tall
around submarine volcanoes you often
find hydrothermal vents there like hot
springs where temperatures can reach up
to 750 degrees Fahrenheit even when the
surrounding waters are near freezing and
they're teeming with life from lobsters
to octopi crabs and worms even in the
fillet genus deep ocean amidst intense
volcanic activity life finds a way
unbelievable
[Music]